it's everyone's dream to go very fast on
the German Autobahn well there it is
right there
and Here I am with a rally driver for
BMW named Lars hi Lars hi and this
amazing car the BMW i8
[Music]
oh yeah oh yeah Lloris this car does not
seem like the kind of car that you would
use to drop your kids off at school
right this part feels more like a car
with that you would drop your third wife
off at school do her pick up hitchhikers
on the road Lars
sorry hitchhikers you know people
looking for a free ride yes I do no we
do in my country with hitchhikers oh we
murder them we are allowed to drive fast
okay now we can go as fast as we want
rice punching pliers yes now it's 174
185 193 yeah that is amazing 210 215 I
just had an orgasm to do that
No well your orgasm is so efficient in
Germany
[Music]
I'm about to drive takeover how do you
feel about that you okay okay the trucks
out overtaking us trucks on the Autobahn
you talk about birch Wow 150 oh we got
to 150 I know that's not so impressive
but there's a lot of traffic right now
what are you yelling German at this man
Goodin Todd could I have would you like
tea one milkshake this we're driving on
the Autobahn this is a sexy car is the
car make me sexy yeah one of the cars
oh right you're getting nervous aren't
you yes I really know you know why are
you nervous
no you didn't have as much beer for
lunch as I did
[Music]
8090
we are too trendy
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
you